Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on guys. This is Rob and we are back again with, uh,
I guess technically it's 10 of swords, but I like calling it extra swords.
I think it just sounds more like an X-Men title when you say it, but, uh,
but we are picking back up with this.
What this does this initially picks up with, uh, with apocalypse right now,
remember apocalypse has largely been in the healing gardens since his returned
from other worlds in the sense that when he was attacked by the four horsemen,
uh, that he,
his body looked like it was quite literally starting to fall apart and his
injuries are pretty extreme, right?
There's no real certainty that he'll actually survive.
And so the people of Precoa and really the, the,
the mutants themselves are faced with a bit of a predicament because of the fact
that apocalypse suffered as injuries and other world. And he would die here.
The implication seems to be that while he wouldn't necessarily die in other
worlds, the effect of dying and other world remains the same.
And the sense that we don't know what version of him would actually come back.
Some alternate reality version,
maybe like the age of apocalypse version of himself,
where he's just hell bent on conquering the world.
And so the result of this is that the healer is basically brought before him for
the purpose of restoring his energies.
The problem with this is the healer cannot actually heal apocalypse on his own
one because of the fact that apocalypse keeps fighting, you know,
and all that kind of stuff because of how much pain he's in.
And so you end up basically having Polaris and Magneto used their combined
powers to strap him down,
but also because the healer's just not powerful enough in his own. Right?
And so the conversation begins to shift by Charles Xavier to having hope summers
amplify,
the powers of healer issue with that is this hasn't really been done before.
And we don't know what the effect would be if it would actually kill apocalypse,
if it would help him survive, there's no real knowing,
but apocalypses response is do it right. If I'm strong enough,
all survive the ordeal. And if I'm not, then I'll know I'm weak.
And so in this point,
apocalypse undergoes the healing at the hands of the healer whose power is
boosted by hope summers. And this is when we get this really,
really cool explanation as to why it is that apocalypse is so hell bent on
testing people. Because one of the things that we saw in the early days of,
of Marvel comics and really kind of the origin that we got from back in the day
is that apocalypse was discovered by ball and the sand stormers right.
They're kind of like this nomad group that was out there.
And he was taught by ball, the philosophy of survival of the fittest,
what this does is this Jonathan Hickman coming back and completely retelling the
origin of apocalypse, right? It's a whole new origin in relation to how it,
how it's based on apocalypse, his desire to test people. That's kind of the,
the funny thing here is that apocalypse leaving, you know,
and there is a little bit of wiggle room there and we'll kind of talk about why
this wiggle room is important here in a second,
but it's basically kind of a flashback sort of,
kind of consolidating a lot of what we were told up to this point.
And the idea was that somewhere along the line,
when you had a Krakatoa and a Rocco, that they were a singular nation, right?
That's something that we've talked about over the course of time.
These were two single islands and that somewhere out of nowhere,
you basically ended up getting these forces of evil, right? These,
these kinds of demonic entities that invaded the world. And because ACARA,
which is what it was called at the time was basically, you know, these two, uh,
you know, uh, Rocco and Coca-Cola existing as a single Island because, Oh,
Carra was effectively a mutant Haven, right?
He was a land where mutans resided those individuals who had popped up around
that time that were largely led by apocalypse, because this was a,
a safe Haven that this was one of the first places to fall,
because it was one of the first places where the horde initially popped up.
And so what you ended up getting was basically 100 soldiers, right?
You ended up getting the white sword who is basically a champion, right?
He was a champion seemingly of the people on this Island.
So maybe apocalypse didn't necessarily rule over them per se,
but him and the 100 went into the portal, right.
They passed into that realm and basically ended up facing off against all these
forces, right? These forces of men. And when that happened, that you,
of course also had Genesis the wife of apocalypse who stepped in as well and
helped to basically curtail these forces and send them back.
The problem with that is you ended up having a situation where a month actually
ended up contacting apocalypse directly, right? And this comes by virtue of, uh,
basically the helm of amaranth being brought forward to apocalypse by the forces
of these demons, right, by the,
all of these different demons and monsters and so on.
And so when one of them opens the box,
he realizes it's the helm and immediately panicked, right.
But he's told by one of the other guys and, you know, annihilation will walk.
The land is basically all God's made men do. And so put the helmet on, right?
Like put this thing on. And then when that happens,
basically Amazon takes over this person. Now,
the way this helm is explained to us by Jonathan Hickman,
the helmet itself is kind of like possessed by this sort of demonic entity,
but we're not given a full on explanation here, right?
We're not given any full answers in terms of who EMyth is or what their place is
or where they are from or any of that stuff.
It's just some kind of demonic being that exists out there. Now,
it really comes straight from the horses mouth, right? That, you know,
Hickman tells us, Amazon is a black planet of black death,
a hellscape of demons and things have a darker origin,
a chaos world of wild space that would be completely uncontrollable to the
living.
If not for the golden helm of annihilation that commands the conquered horde of
Amman, the person who wears the helm rules that dark world,
but the helmet itself rules, the were possessed by some elder God,
a primordial force of the spirit of that world made manifest.
The helm is seductive.
The helm is all consuming and only aware of greater strength.
Howard can hope to live through the experience, right?
It's a crown for the fit and only the fit can rule the amount, the health,
right? So there's this spirit basically, or this, this being,
it's almost kind of like, uh, the,
the essence of this demonic world that all these forces come from right now. We,
again, we don't really know what's goal or its ambition,
but the long and short is that when it possesses this demon and it starts
speaking directly to apocalypse that it says, I I'm, I'm giving you an offering,
but I cannot give it to you freely. Right. I must test you.
I must know whether or not you're worthy of receiving this offering.
And so what ends up happening is a couple of these demons,
basically challenge apocalypse as forces specifically Genesis.
And initially it was going to be apocalypse himself who was going to challenge
these guys, but, you know, the,
the ones who receive the offering or the one to undergo the test to determine
whether or not they were worth receiving the offering,
but instead his wife Genesis steps up. And when that happens,
she basically uses her power seemingly over the earth to destroy or to defeat
these two, you know, these two demonic beings. And then in turn,
you end up having this, this kind of offer that's made to her, you know, this,
this, you know, uh, Memphis demon, right by Amazon basically.
And when that happens,
we don't really know what the offer was that was made to them,
the wife of apocalypse Genesis herself, instead,
all we know is that in the aftermath of this,
that basically they had to travel to that realm and they had to close the rift.
Right. They had to close that portal and cut ACARA in half.
That's kind of what led to that, right? That's what led to, uh,
Krakatoa becoming its own Island and a Rocco becoming its own place inside of
other worlds, basically. And so in that moment, that's when,
when essentially the IBS seems to be that like a future battle will be fought,
right? That like, you know, we will give you safe Haven or whatever it is,
or we, and I have no real idea, but like in the future, you know,
things are gonna pop off. And so with that being the case, Genesis tasks,
her husband with testing, right? She says,
you're not strong enough to follow me to this realm,
stay and use the time that we buy you to make this world into something that can
stand against our enemy. Right? Judge them, my love judge them all.
And that's why apocalypse does what he does. He's tasked.
Or he was tasked by his wife to travel the world and to basically make it a
place where only the strong could survive. Because at some future point in time,
this strong will be the only ones capable of surviving against this coming horde
of, of the [inaudible] army. Right?
So apocalypse has quite literally been following this philosophy in order to
prepare the world for this army that is set to invade and then unleash all
kinds of Holy hell. Right?
So that's really the whole idea behind this is why apocalypse does what he does.
This is a massive change to his entire history, right?
Because we didn't really know the, the,
the kind of blanks that were being left there,
like kind of referencing what we talked about, you know,
earlier when we said that we would come back and explain this,
that the traditional history of apocalypse is that he was discovered by ball in
the sand storms. When he was a baby, he was taken under their wing.
He was taught the philosophy that only the strong deserve to survive this kind
of social Darwinist ideology.
But the origin at the time was that was an ideology.
That ball hat that was an ideology has tribe hat.
And they pass that ideology onto apocalypse.
And that's why he does what he does.
What Hickman's doing here is coming in and saying, none of that's true.
The reason why apocalypse test the world,
the way he does is because he knew a conflict was going to be coming at some
future point in time, right? 5,000 years, 10,000 years,
20,000 years into the future. And he's constantly been,
been touching the world in order to make sure it's strong enough to survive it.
This completely changes the motivation for why apocalypse does what he does.
It's not because he's a Dick it's because he's been trying to make sure the
world can save itself. Right? That's a huge change. It's a massive change.
And so once he fully recovers, he ends up traveling to, uh, to,
to the Libyan desert, right in Western Egypt to the temple of the four horsemen,
right to the temple of the horsemen and, and really to his own resting place.
And when he gets there, of course,
he goes inside and then he basically ends up taking a sword and,
and essentially grabs a sword and then travels back to take his place.
Really it's as seemingly the final piece on the, the swords of X landscape,
the final piece that's here, uh,
as part of the excess words event and the final hero among cacoa,
who's going to face off against the forces of a Rocco. Well, that being said,
guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to come and explain to make sure you guys at the sub button
to become part of the Rob Ford. If you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a, like, now we'll catch you all later.
Bruce.
[inaudible].